naomi is with us naomi
screwed that up all right let's see here
naomi is in fresno hi naomi how are you
hi dave i'm doing well so i have to
connect with you guys how are you
great how can we help okay dave so
i'm kind of lost um i
just got summoned last week and
i'm being sued for two credit cards for
bank of america
and so i talked to an attorney attorney
said
okay in your situation uh we can go
ahead and do bankruptcy
uh chapter seven yeah this would be a
bankruptcy attorney
uh asking a bankruptcy attorney if
you're bankrupt's like asking a dog if
it's hungry
true yeah so how much of the balance on
these credit cards
okay so for in total it's about
uh thirteen thousand so one you don't
file bankruptcy over thirteen thousand
dollars naomi
no why haven't you paid why haven't you
paid them what
uh i'm sorry why have you not been able
to pay them hon
um i was paying i had a personal loan so
i started paying that
and then i had another credit card with
citibank so i
started paying that as well and then i
have foot surgery
and then i had to take on another job
which i took a pay cut because i moved
um
so pretty much i just kind of felt and
uh on my payments
yeah and so what do you make now i have
what do you make now i'm on uh
i'm on unemployment and i make about two
weeks they give me about 1400. okay
they're not gonna get anything if they
sue you
you don't have anything i don't i don't
even have a car
they can't get they can't get
unemployment
and i also have another car for capital
one which i owe five thousand
doesn't matter they can't get anything
you don't have anything
so your problem is not your debt your
problem is your income
that you don't have right
i mean if you got a job making 30 000 a
year we can walk you out of this in no
time
yeah and i think it's you're not
bankrupt honey you're trying to live on
unemployment and life is not designed to
do that
you have no income right and i'm correct
and i'm moving in two weeks
to uh down to socal um
so i'm hoping that by then maybe in two
three weeks i can
find a full-time job and maybe get a
little more income
you're moving right to socal
southern california why you keep moving
yeah uh because
my boyfriend's um job
kind of keeps him moving around so this
is probably like the fourth time we've
moved
in like the past probably three years
yeah when are you figuring out this
ain't working for you
it's not working for me so quit
following him around and being broke
yeah i actually thought about it i
actually thought about just leaving and
kind of doing my own thing
and but with my financial situation it's
just been kind of hard
yeah um the financial situation is you
don't have a job
right and it's hard because of what
because of what you've been doing for
the last three years it might actually
get easier if you could have an income
if you had if you could stay put in one
place and get a job
and make some good money that could fix
this whole thing yeah
you can clean up this debt in no time
once you get your career goals
straightened out and get your life
straightened out kiddo
you do not have a debt problem you have
a life problem and a career problem
and your career problem stems from your
life problem
because you're following dubai around
and you've got no life
yeah that's pretty much it yeah so at
this point it's like
i really don't know what to do and i
figured maybe you could do
you know if bankruptcy would be an
option no
it doesn't it doesn't help it doesn't
help sweet naomi what helps sweet naomi
is when sweet naomi starts valuing
sweet naomi's the quality of life over
following duber around
you are worth more than this you are
more valuable than this girl
the only way you get to follow duber to
socal is when you make more than he
makes
and you start telling him what to do
because this is this is drain the the
bone marrow
out of your life you have no money you
have no career
you have no income and you're calling me
about filing bankruptcy on a tiny tiny
little amount of debt
that could be cleared up in no time i
can settle thirteen thousand dollars
that bank of america is suing you on
for probably two thousand bucks but you
ain't seen two thousand bucks in a long
time
kiddo no i do have a savings
you have a career problem
you have to get your income going and
you have to get
you have to value naomi enough to put
naomi at the front of the list
naomi's getting troubled on she's taking
care of everybody but naomi
am i wrong no you're not wrong you're
not wrong sound like i'm being too tough
on her no sweet girl
seriously sweet girl love yourself a
little bit it's not a bad thing it's not
being selfish